tommy you have designed a big
big wall had people try to go up and
over it i feel that this is the
lamborghini of walls
it's got a very aesthetic look to it why
build an ugly wall
so this is a story about an individual
called tommy fisher
he built a three-mile wall the next step
was can i
sell it that hasn't happened yet and
what was it like to have the president
check out the prototype today the larger
it is the better it is because it's very
hard to get over the top
he completed the wall in early 2020 and
since then has been embroiled in
various lawsuits it's one of a kind
[Music]
this is no ordinary border wall there
are three things notable about it
one it's located in the rio grande
valley home to more illegal border
crossings and more seas cocaine and pot
than anywhere else in the country two
it's located directly on the banks of
the rio grande river
where for legal and environmental
reasons construction of a border wall
has never been attempted
and three it's privately owned by a guy
from north dakota named tommy fisher
we're presently standing on the banks of
the rio grande river with a three mile
border protection system behind me
located about two miles south of mission
texas
tommy fisher built a three mile long
privately funded
border wall most of the land is
privately owned ranchers farmers
individual homeowners
it's on the banks of the river which
already serves as a natural barrier
and also makes it extremely difficult
for legal and geographic and
environmental reasons to build anything
to me when you see it stand up and it'll
last the test of time
that's just my feeling harmony fisher is
a midwestern nice he doesn't see his
wall as an object of exclusion
i'm for legal immigration illegal
immigration i'm not
he sees it as a law enforcement aide
more than that he sees it as a business
opportunity
i think when president trump came into
office it gave me an
idea that he wanted a very long linear
project
something that was never built in the
history of america so it was
it was more of a catalyst to say hey
could could their project
have this magnitude really be built
joining us now for reaction is a ceo who
submitted one of those prototypes
the first time any private organization
has built border wall on private land
joining us to talk about all this is
tommy fisher the next step was
can i sell it and make back my money on
it or commission
somebody to get me to do more of these
after the 2016 election
fisher mounted a right-wing media blitz
to pitch his wall building services in
washington
and attracted attention from a
non-profit named we build the wall
founded by triple amputee iraq war
veteran brian colfaj
and steve bannon who would go on to pay
fisher 6.9 million dollars
we built the wall gave him several
million dollars to build one structure
pretty short structure in new mexico
they built it
encouraged by this first structure
fisher starts construction on a second
wall
this one near the rio grande funded by
we build the wall
the group sends him a first payment of
1.5 million dollars but then
the payment stopped and the legal
troubles started
fast forward to summer of 2020 bannon
and his
alleged co-conspirators are arrested for
essentially defrauding their supporters
they're alleged to have run out of money
and they stopped sending money to tommy
fisher fisher wasn't implicated
and decides to fund the rest of his wall
using his own money
but yet again the project is met with
legal troubles he's sued by
the federal government which says you
can't do that because you could screw
with the rio grande river and it's going
to move the u.s mexico boundary
he's sued by a wildlife preserve called
the national butterfly center which says
essentially
you're going to flood our property and
drown our butterflies
the north american butterfly association
was granted
a temporary restraining order to stop
construction of a border wall
fischer contested the suits and even as
federal prosecutors hover around rebuild
the wall
his company is given contracts to build
federal wall sections in arizona and
texas
fisher was granted over two billion
dollars in federal wall building
contracts
but then joe biden won the 2020
presidential election
there will not be another foot of wall
constructed
in my administration but all of this
doesn't stop fisher from pushing for his
wall
after biden's election fisher's project
gets renewed momentum from a growing
crisis at the border
this morning at the southern border more
than fifteen thousand migrant children
are in federal custody
baby bottles and shoes and we saw this
all over along the border
a group of 80 migrants including many
children turn themselves in
after making the dangerous trek across
the rio grande
the biden administration has been
greeted with a large influx of
migrants from central america and fisher
is arguing essentially that his wall
is going to solve this issue
fischer built his wall in south texas
because there is almost no
federal wall that exists in south texas
at all almost all the federal wall that
was built during the george w
bush administration the obama
administration and the trump
administration
is in california new mexico and arizona
us coming from america we're a country
of laws
i was always for that if we could help
um assist that
and help our government and help every
single american
you know we want to be on the leading
edge he successfully created a proof of
concept
and he's trying to get texas maybe to
buy it but at 20 million dollars a mile
that's a tough ask my hope is is that
the new administration would come down
and talk to the boots on the ground that
could see
something that was built on the rio
grande that could have so many multiple
purposes
not only could it be for border
protection but it could also be for a
public use
bike path different things but some
would argue that tommy fisher's
three-mile wall does not in fact address
the issue
the government accountability office
testified that it had not developed any
way of measuring whether border fencing
had any effect
there's this question do border walls
work
it's hard it's hard to say if you're an
immigrant seeking asylum
they're not trying to evade law
enforcement at all
they're often walking right up to
wherever the border fence is so in that
sense
no wall in texas is going to address
that issue
[Music]
thanks for watching for more videos like
this you can stream bloomberg quick take
for free 24
7 in any of the places below get live
news coverage interviews deep dives
shows and documentaries on the stories
you care about most and be sure to
follow us or subscribe to us on twitter
youtube instagram
and facebook
you